you're going out
oh mine's already out okay so did you
put up some
did you put up some stuff for us to call
okay so i just sent you a number for a
laundromat a what a laundry mat or i
have a little let's call the laundry bag
okay we can't both do it so yeah but we
can both watch we'll both okay i'll just
bring you in i'll start it and then you
bring it in
where's the laundry mat give me the
laundry mat
we're gonna call on you man
should have shaved my arms okay
oh i can't with it we can't with the
chips with these around i'm sorry that's
got to stop
i can't do it i can't do that i'm
actually just got mad okay
is
are you serious poor girlfriend it's
it's uh
are you okay with the chewing sounds no
he's not you don't listen to asmr
uh they're old stuff
they're old stuff all right stop with
the chips
stop with the chips
what's all that all over the mic i don't
know sour cream
and onion
all right we did get a couple of
comments about the chips we got we got a
couple that said they're not listening
anymore because of the chips but i read
the couple that said they want more
there's no middle ground when it comes
to chips it's either me or him they
don't understand people don't understand
art it's the product i'll tell you
where's the dry cleaner you should sell
chips as merch i texted you the number
oh well you gotta tell you can't just
text me and i'm not checking
that
wait
did you hear that we should sell chips
as merch he said
that's a good idea yeah where do we get
our what here we go and call him laish
there we go and i'll bring you in
okay yes um
can you help me for a second
is there any way how fast how fast is
there a turnaround as far as uh cleaning
what's the fastest have a drop-off
service right now
what do you mean
well are you looking to drop it off you
mean you want to drop off your clothes
okay so how do you want to come in and
do it yourself
oh
all right so here's what we don't have
we don't have a um fluff and fold this
is just do it yourself i know but here's
what i want to say i have um
okay i have these so one wash at the
washi the wash usually lasts about 26
minutes but here's what i want to ask
is there any way because i have nothing
to do with your equipment i have uh
clothes that are
they're soaked in blood and what i need
is after the wash when i leave i need
the entire the dryer and the washer
disinfected
um
and i also if somebody
if the police or whoever if you guys are
getting questioned or called how can i
keep that
a secret so that you don't divulge any
information
is this a joke
um it it is
ma'am
this is far from a joe
well then why would i want to why would
i not i mean i'm not like abating you
with freaking washington bloody clothes
no we you just said well dude i have my
buddy rick is with me here he's going to
be doing the washing and the laundry
stop it yeah uh yes he's joking uh yeah
well yes we do have bloody stuff it's
not from obviously you're not gonna call
the police or anything but it is a
little uncomfortable coming in with some
bloody stuff our dog recently passed
away giving
um giving birth to her puppies and it's
a
she was okay with the murder she was
okay she was okay with murder i was
trying to make it seem more real
and people don't like real you don't
respond
she'll talk to me about a murder and how
she's going to divulge through the
police but as soon as you said you had
birthing puppies oh i'm [ __ ] out of
here i think i am not going to deal with
puppy [ __ ]
like i think she i think she was out on
the uh uh
uh
okay no
oh
i'm so sorry
that's why you don't ask you never ask
i know that's a terrible question well
if you want more of those what we call
medium prank phone calls tune in next
week when we have kayla coming on to
talk about her crickets my name is rick
glassman from the take your shoes off
podcast and here is part two the music
[Music]